le Sénat c'est l'une des deux Chambres
du Parlement français il siège au Palais
du Luxembourg et avec l'Assemblée
nationale il détient le pouvoir
législatif les deux assemblées du
Parlement sont chargé d'examiner et de
voter les lois de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et d'évaluer les politiques
publiques contrairement à l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat ne peut pas être
dissou il est le garant de la stabilité
des institutions et joue un rôle de
contrepouvoir
comme l'indique l'article 24 de la
Constitution le Sénat est chargé de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales en effet les 348 sénateurs
sont élus au suffrage universel indirect
par 162000 grands électeurs parmi
lesquels on retrouve essentiellement les
maires et les élus municipaux
départementaux et régionaux de
l'hexagone et
d'outremire 12 sénateurs représent les
Français établis hors de
France pour être candidat aux élections
sénatoriales il faut avoir au minimum 24
ans et le plus jeune sénateur a été élu
à l'âge de 26 ans la durée du mandat est
de 6 ans et tous les 3 ans le Sénat est
renouvelé par moitié ce qui assure une
continuité dans ses choix et ses
orientations au fil des élections la
part des femmes élus sénatrice a
fortement
augmenté le président du Sénat est le
deuxème personnage de l'État c'est lui
qui assure l'intérim lorsque le
président de la République n'est plus en
mesure d'assumer ses fonctions dans
l'hémicycle les sénateurs sont placés
selon leur groupe et leur orientation
politique c'est dans ce lieu
emblématique que sont prises toutes les
décisions concernant les textes de
loi chaque sénateur est membre d'une
commission
permanente mais il peut aussi faire
partie de l'une des délégations du Sénat
ou de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques le contrôle du
gouvernement et l'évaluation des
politiques publiques est l'autre grande
mission du Sénat ce contrôle s'exerce en
séance publique et de façon permanente
par le travail des commissions et des
délégations ces travaux donnent lieu à
de nombreuses auditions et à des
déplacements sur le
terrain les commissions d'enquête
permettent de se saisir des sujets les
plus graves les personnes entendues
doivent prêter serement et les sénateurs
disposeent de véritables pouvoirs
d'investigation les conclusions tirées
de ces enquêtes mission permettent de
proposer de nouvelles pistes pour
réformer le pays sur le site internet du
Sénat vous pouvez retrouver tous les
éléments pour suivre l'examen des textes
la séance en direct le travail des
commissions les rapports des sénateurs
et bien d'autres ressources
encore le Sénat consulte régulièrement
les citoyens et les élus locaux pour
nourrir ses travaux vous pouvez
également déposer ou soutenir une
pétition en ligne pour demander au Sénat
de faire évoluer la loi ou de lancer un
contrôle
le Sénat est également ouvert aux
visiteurs plus de 250000 personnes
viennent chaque année visiter le Palais
du Luxembourg notamment pendant les
Journées Européennes du Patrimoine vous
pouvez également retrouver l'actualité
du Sénat sur les réseaux sociaux YouTube
Twitter Facebook Instagram TikTok et
LinkedIn